bonfort nous sommes le mercredi 21
octobre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de votre actualité locale
le front national entre en campagne
aujourd'hui philippe chevrier tête de
liste front national dans les yvelines a
tenu après c'était ce midi à versailles
il a présenté les élus de la liste et a
rappelé les objectifs et le programme du
fn et quand cristiano ronaldo rencontre
adam ibrahimovic c'est forcément pour un
match au sommet le psg rencontre le real
de madrid en ligue des champions ce soir
au parc des princes retour sur
l'entraînement des deux équipes entre le
camp des loges à saint-germain-en-laye
et le parc des princes enfin
connaissez-vous le tueur en série ted
bundy il est l'un des serial killers les
plus célèbres de l'histoire des états
unis
l'association au jury ce jeu reste
tribune de l'université de versailles
saint quentin 2 constitue son procès ce
vendredi yacine pommier ex-président et
solène feillard vice présidente de
l'association étudiants sont en plateau
avec nous et nous en parlerons et pour
ouvrir à cette édition revient sur la
polémique des audits de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines othman à ce
rouleau président de promo paul a décidé
de rendre publique l'audit réalisé sur
la pépinière d'entreprises en juillet
2014 sur son site internet www.om.net
roux point fr cette décision intervient
dans le cadre du débat sur les audits à
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
l'inventaire de la gestion de la
majorité socialiste précédente
sandrine gang rengot conseillère
régionale d'île de france et vice
président de la casse qui avait demandé
après la conférence de presse du 13
octobre dernier organisée par la
nouvelle majorité à ce sujet de pouvoir
consulter ces audits et retour sur les
élections régionales philippe chevrier
tête de liste front national dans les
yvelines a tenu un point presse ce midi
à versailles je vous le disais en titre
l'occasion de présenter les cinq
premiers élus de la liste front national
et de rappeler leur objectif obtenir
cinq sièges sur 27 dans les yvelines
et d'annoncer également l'adhésion
récente de mireille breugnot
anciennement élus divers droite sur la
lite sur la liste d'ousmane nassr ou
dans les élections municipales de 2014
fanny bourdillon et camille lambert
philippe chevrier tête de liste fn dans
les yvelines a présenté ce midi à
versailles
les cinq principaux élus qui
l'accompagneront dans les prochaines
élections régionales de décembre avec un
objectif clair conquérir un maximum de
sièges
mon objectif c'est d'avoir le plus de
buts possible voilà un pour que s'arrête
la gabegie de la région ile-de-france
mené actuellement par la majorité
socialiste mais main dans la main avec
nos amis républicains lors de cette
conférence mireille brugnon a annoncé sa
nouvelle adhésion au front national il y
a un an elle quittait le groupe trappe
citoyens d'autres magnats through de
divers droite
elle siègera désormais au conseil
municipal de trappes sous l'étiquette fn
et nous explique son choix
j'étais très déçu très déçu et de l'ump
j'adhère et trois ans et l'ump en fait
et je n'ai pas renouvelé en 2013 je n'ai
pas renouvelé
on a des hommes en france et de la
misère je peux vous dire que les gens
qui attendent qui attend pour les
logements pour le travail pour la
sécurité aussi
et donc moins ces valeurs se rapproche
vraiment j'ai découvert dans un front
national des valeurs auxquelles j'adhère
le parti de marine le pen compte
désormais 1500 adhérents dans les
yvelines le fn remporterait 21% des
intentions de vote dans notre
département et nous allons maintenant
parler du procès de ted bundy le célèbre
tueur en série américain qui a rejoué
reconstitué par l'association juriste
tribune de l'université de saint quentin
en yvelines
bonsoir à vous deux et merci d'être
venus en plateau alors yassine toumi
vous êtes l'ex-président de gérer ce
tribune c'est vous qui allez jouer tel
bundy oui oui c'est moi qui l'honneur
dans le lot de tâche de le faire et cela
ne fait guère vous êtes la vice
présidente de jury tribune en charge de
la reconstitution du procès alors pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas ted bundy
ses taux mais les années 1970 a agressés
assassinés de nombreuses jeunes femmes
et filles peu de temps avant son
exécution il admet avoir commis trente
homicide dans cet état différent entre
1974 et 1978 il a été exécuté sur la
chaise électrique à la prison d'état de
floride alors le nombre de victimes
demeurent encore inconnues mais pour
être réglés relevé un peu plus tard
pourquoi vous avez choisi de rejouer ce
procès en fait on a choisi de rejouer le
procès de ted bundy dans l'idée de
refaire un procès international
l'an dernier on a créé justement l'une
deuxième reconstitution de procès à
l'origine je resterai une ne faisait
qu'une que une c'était assure un procès
français c'était aux alentours du mois
de février mars et on a baissé dans le
projet le procès à londres et c'est
exactement procès d'andré notamment il
l'an dernier c'était le procès
et omar haddad main bras dessus et non
dernier on a créé un procès
international
on a d'abord fait la sphère kennedy et
ensuite on voulait trouver une autre
affaire internationale alors le problème
de 9,1 en affaires internationales s'il
faut qu'elle passionne il faut qu'elle
ait un véritable intérêt à être rejoué
et la ferté bundy elle est parfaite pour
ça justement voilà c'est un petit peu
les tueurs en série beaucoup de gens qui
sont fascinés par ce phénomène qui a
beaucoup plus eu lieu aux états unis
qu'en france c'est ce que justement nous
avons demandé à certains un saint
quentinois qu'ils étaient intéressés
partage propose de regarder leurs
témoignages
je pense que c'est surtout le fait
qu'ils aient la sensation la recherche
de sensations fortes
la recherche de comme dans les films
d'action un peu
on aime beaucoup regardé des séries
américaines où il ya des tueurs en série
c'est écoeurant c'est tout mais la
fascination
non je vois pas je vais pas fasciné par
eux mais bon je me demande pourquoi ils
font ça et donc je vais voir un peu sur
internet tout ça mais après je peux que
je comprends pas pourquoi il ya des
personnes qui sont aussi fasciné après
ils vont commettre faire par exemple des
imitations quoi pas parce que c'est
laisser les barbares donc on ne peut pas
comprendre quelqu'un qui résonne comme
un au revoir quand on regarde eux leur
mode de pensée c'est pas du tout le même
que le nôtre et ça c'est un peu par
péter reichard et services pour charger
c'est ce que vous disiez bas il ya un
peu la fascination c'est pour intéresser
les étudiants qu'il avait choisi ce cas
spécifique
oui absolument pas ce que l'on sait bien
que quand on reconstitue un procès si
c'est un procès qui il n'y a pas assez
pas un événement assez important ça va
pas intéresser les étudiants ont fait du
droit
donc forcément on s'intéresse un petit
peu à tout ça et donc forcément un
procès international comme ça aussi
c'est un des plus grand serial killer
des états unis qui a tué plus de 36
familles les il a renoncé à ses
assassins gore c'est oui sur ford à
l'asse mais du coup ça on s'est créé pas
plus intéressé des étudiants que
quelqu'un qui a entre guillemets tu es
une seule personne et on sait pas
vraiment là on sait qu il est là tuez le
personnage en lui-même est assez
intéressant puisque au début ils
reconnaissaient pas du tout ces meurtres
et après son procès après qu'il ait été
condamné à la peine de mort il a reconnu
par la suite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de meurtres et on n'est pas sûr qu'ils
les aient tous reconnus ou quoi alors
vous rejoins ce procès dont il fut donc
peut-être différent que je m'emploie
différents sur quoi vous avez travaillé
quand vous êtes préparés parce que
disons que le procès a lieu aux états
unis ce n'est pas les mêmes droits qu'en
france du coup non alors du coup il leur
fait avec le droit américain c'est ça
qui est intéressant aussi pour les
étudiants ont fait un premier procès
avec en droit américain donc là le
procès d'être ted bundy
et on en refera sûrement un par la suite
avec le droit français du coup là il va
y avoir les objections le jeu
s'appellera votre mère un peu comme dans
les séries américaines ou qu'on sait que
les étudiants aiment beaucoup ça aussi
il signe en quoi ça peut être
intéressant pour des étudiants voilà en
droit d'avoir rejoint cette approche du
droit américain
c'est intéressant pour eux ne serait ce
que pour mettre pour la plupart d'entre
eux sont des premières années qui
viendront mettre les pieds dans un
tribunal
c'est une étape c'est vrai que on nous
encourage souvent allé assister à des
procès mais bon déjà c'est pas évident
que les étudiants et iai et là ça les
invite à se rendre dans un tribunal
avoir un petit peu l'ambiance qui peut y
avoir dans un tribunal et de voir aussi
un petit peu la gravité de ce qui peut
se passer dans un tribunal parce que les
cours et les la théorie est bien faite
mais quand
en théorie on se rend compte que le
meurtre et est puni par la loi on ne se
rend pas compte de ce que c'est d'avoir
un meurtrier qui ce fait jugé devant les
familles des victimes devant des témoins
devant et c'est vrai que voir un juge
qui décide comme ça en plus dans le
droit américain c'est vraiment le juge
qui a vraiment le plein pouvoir et de
voir un juge qui a montré guillemets
pouvoir de vie ou de mort sur un homme
ça ça tout ça c'est là tout l'intérêt
pour les étudiants c'est de se
confronter finalement la réalité du
monde juridique et finalement à sa
cruauté en fait donc c'était un objectif
pédagogique c'est important voilà deux
c'est un complément fait des cours pour
vous voilà c'est ça on court on va
surtout l'aspect théorique et là c'est
plus l'aspect pratique
montre aux étudiants ce qu'ils vont
vraiment faire dans la vie mais
finalement de kayes et risquent ils
d'être très peu confrontés quand même
oui à voir ce qu'ils vont vraiment se
tourner vers le droit pénal mais c'est
quand même assez intéressant de pouvoir
voir cet aspect là de la justice pour
voir que ça peut quand même aller très
très loin même si c'est plus rare que
beaucoup d'autres choses comme les le
droit de la famille avec le divorce tout
ça c'est quand même assez intéressant de
voir jusqu'où sait jusqu'où ça peut
aller comme le disait yacine le juge
qu'il ya quand même qu'il ya quand même
décider de la vie ou de la mort d'un
homme
alors tout le monde a faim voilà comme
ça il y en a c'est très pédagogique
montpellier c'était une question qui
n'est pas étudiant en droit peut y aller
s'informer sur ce procès bien sûr on
encourage tous ceux qui veulent venir à
venir il faut venir tôt parce que
souvent le tribunal et remplit toujours
mais par contre il faut vraiment venir
c'est à dire que si on est intéressé par
le droit ou simplement pas les faire ou
simplement juste par pure culture
générale en soit il faut il faut venir
c'est vraiment là c'est l'occasion de
voir des étudiants qui qui se mobilisent
qu'ils se qui se motive pour faire
quelque chose d'extra scolaire c'est pas
toujours évident et c'est fait de
manière extrêmement rigoureuse c'est
encadré par des professeurs on a un
nouveau docteur en droit qui qui nous
accompagne pour le projet jean baptiste
duclair donc on a vraiment c'est
vraiment un bel accompagnement
pédagogique donc c'est vrai que c'est un
travail très sérieux
yacine bundy j'ai postulé oui
complètement en fait j'ai postulé
parce que je trouvais le personnage
tellement complexe
dans leur document documents que vous
avez diffusé j'ai entendu une personne
parler de barbares ted bundy tout sauf
barbares dans ses actes et dense est
effectivement dans ces crimes c'est
vraiment des actes de barbarie mais le
personnage en lui-même est étonnamment
calme serein intelligent sans prétention
il est extrêmement méthodique et a
toujours un recul sur ce qu'il fait a
toujours c'est vraiment un personnage
extrêmement complexe et son procès
d'ailleurs c'est un procès où il se
défend lui-même ceci ça l'intéresse aux
faussaires ted bundy considérait son
avocat comme un incompétent et un
imbécile donc ted bundy s'est défendu
lui-même sa défense pour allah pour
m'être renseigné sur sur la défense qui
là qu'il a proposée est une défense de
qualité énorme faim c'est pour qu'il y
passe un avocat et qui ont par dessus
est un tueur en série en scène a demandé
à pas mal de préparation est même en
préparation en préparation sur skis sur
le droit en général sur la défense tout
court et puis sur le personnage
alors justement là ça demande beaucoup
d'organisation tout quand vous avez un
peu attribué les rôles on commence à
voir un peu ce passé vous a mis beaucoup
de temps pour travailler fort pour
aboutir ce projet alors oui on travaille
depuis depuis le mois de juillet donc
c'est assez long parce qu'il faut
remonter tout le dossier pour retrouver
toutes les preuves
ensuite une fois que le dossier complet
et créer c'est à dire qu'on refait une
biographie on recherche toutes les
preuves les témoins qui étaient présents
et ensuite il faut trouver des
personnages pour jouer les témoins les
jurés aussi parce que il faut savoir que
aux états unis il ya douze jurés
quand on fait un procès comme ça en
droit pénal donc du coup il faut il faut
retrouver tout le monde
on a un professeur donc monsieur jean
baptiste duclair qui vient pour jouer le
rôle du juge un avocat monsieur par m
philippe gérard qui vient pour faire le
rôle du procureur et yacine qui fait le
rôle le rôle de ted bundy
et donc il faut on s'est vraiment un
travail très rond parce que j'y
travaille depuis le mois de juillet eh
bien nous suivrons ça il aura un
reportage assure téléfilm justement sur
la reconstitution du procès nous serons
là merci à vous d'être venu en plateau
et nous en a pas reparlé je le rappelle
donc la reconstitution du procès de ted
bundy a lieu vendredi au tribunal de
grande instance de versailles de 13h à
18h et samedi dernier toujours à
versailles se tenait le congrès du
secours populaire tous les deux ans les
délégués départementaux de l'association
caritative se réunissent pour établir un
rapport
non c'est et définir les axes
prioritaires pour les années à venir
un bilan mitigé pour l'antenne illinoise
qui constate une forte augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires sur ces quatre
dernières années
william el est patrick jane de nick
snyder chaque année ce qu'elle dirait
bien éveillé plus à passer les portes du
secours populaire pour venir chercher un
soutien supplémentaire une hausse du
nombre de bénéficiaires inquiétante pour
pascal rodier président de l'antenne
yvelinoise qui constate également une
augmentation des bénévoles et des
donateurs
la difficulté que nous avons c'est qu'il
nous faudrait encore plus de ressources
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir continuer de
nous développer puisque là on arrive
quand même un petit peu à des seuils
notamment dans certaines municipalités
on n'a pas forcément les locaux pour
faire la solidarité comme on aimerait
les mureaux où ils sartrouville ou
encore monter son sont les principales
communes concernées par ce manque de
locaux au secours populaire l'inquiétude
porte aussi sur l'accroissement du
nombre de personnes âgées bénéficiaires
autre difficulté aborder celle de l'aide
apportée aux personnes hébergées à
l'hôtel il est difficile de s'organiser
puisque il faut qu'elle sache un petit
peu comment fonctionnent les
institutions en france comment les
associations peuvent aider il ya une
problématique de maîtrise du français
pour beaucoup d'entre eux est une très
grande précarité une assez mauvaise
information au niveau des droits et donc
c'est un public qui ne pas nous falloir
aborder plus systématiquement le secours
populaire français est présent à
l'international dans plus de 70 pays
l'antenne yvelinoise quant à elle est
présente en ethiopie au niger et au mali
et comptes consolidés son aide apportée
au continent africain
autre projet développé laisser plus de
place aux jeunes au sein de
l'association et renforcer la présence
du secours populaire en milieu scolaire
c'est une profession dédié sa vie à la
musique
à mi chemin entre l'artiste et l'
artisan luthier et le spécialiste et des
instruments à cordes frottées nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de stéphane
garnier le luthier de versailles il a
accepté de nous parler de son métier
regarder son témoignage
il est dans son atelier comme au milieu
d'un orchestre entouré de violons
violoncelles altos contrebasses ces
instruments qu'il affectionne et à qui
leur donne une seconde vie stéphane
garnier lüthi à versailles c'est un peu
le chirurgien des instruments à cordes
frottées il était en trois parties donc
là j'ai procédé au collage n'a depuis
plus de vingt ans il fabrique réparé ou
restaure les biens les plus précieux des
musiciens avec qui ils partagent la même
passion et violoncelliste et donc c'est
mon présent au violoncelle qui m'a donné
l'idée de devenir luthier et assez tard
d'ailleurs je vais jetter déjà grands
grands ados et
depuis que j'ai eu cette idée ça ne va
plus lâcher je voyais pas ce que je
pouvais faire d'autre ce métier
artisanal demande minutie et précision
stéphane a étudié quatre ans dans une
école suisse pour parfaire son art
quatre années ont fait que ça sa part de
sava de l'atelier afin de l'établi pour
en reparler en passant par l'histoire de
la lutherie mais aussi toute théorie
musicale acoustic physique acoustique
sur les vernis assez complète de la
chine et un violon par exemple
nécessitent beaucoup d'entretien chaque
année il doit passer entre les mains du
luthier pour être examinés car l'objet
est très fragile il ya des partis qui
s'usent il ya la mèche de l'archet il
faut changer les corps de susi
et puis l entretien de de soins à ce que
je fais pas en place et les touches de
vernis et etc le bois le finisse par
partir en écharde en lambeaux les
innovations qui peut y avoir c'est
souvent qu'on retrouve des choses
anciennes et voilà on c'est un
instrument totalement aboutie comment
merveilleux stéphane garnier là sur le
métier ne se perd pas et lui ne
quitterait la cité royale pour rien au
monde
versailles est une ville extrêmement
riche culturellement donc la musique ya
évidemment un trait une très grande
place et jeu
fier enfin je peux rebondir très très
très heureux de pouvoir être le luthier
de versailles
luthier un métier d'art mis à l'honneur
à l'occasion de la première cour des
métiers d'art elle aura lieu le 13 14 et
15 novembre prochains au palais des
congrès de versailles
à quelques pas du château on les voit
souvent sur le toit des maisons ou
encore dans les champs et si demain vous
rouliez sur des panneaux solaires c'est
en tout cas ce qu'a développé la société
colas dont le centre technique est basée
à manille les va'a nous pourrons parler
avec n'ont pas tous ce soir mélanie poké
notre journaliste spécialiste de
l'environnement
bonsoir mélanésiens soeur flora alors
l'énergie solaire on connaît tous vous
l'avez dit certains d'entre nous ont des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur le toit de
leur maison
la route solaire ou à toi comme l'a
nommé le groupe colas c'est
l'aboutissement de cinq ans de travaux
et de recherche ça a été fait en
partenariat avec l'insee l'institut
national de l'énergie solaire et à magny
les hameaux ses 40 mètres carrés de
route solaire qui ont été installés et
chaque panneau mesure 1 m 75 par 70 cm
alors de quoi sont faites les routes
solaire à mélanie comment sont elles
fabriquées
alors c'est en fait un millefeuille de
différents matériaux il ya bien sûr des
cellules photovoltaïques et il ya
différentes couches protectrices
notamment fait de résine pour protéger
les cellules
le tout fait 7 mm d'épaisseur
écoutez philippe raffin le directeur
technique recherche et développement du
groupe en termes de matériaux ce sont
des matériaux translucides pour pouvoir
capter cette énergie solaire donc ces
composés d'une résine translucide et du
verre en surface pour assurer
l'adhérence nécessaire
comme toute route traditionnellement
alors c'est pas nous ils peuvent
vraiment supporter le poids d'une
voiture 1 panneaux photovoltaïques c'est
très fragile ça une épaisseur de 200
microns vous faire une idée de 100
microns c'est 0,2 mm
philippe raffin nous a fait une
démonstration c'est très fragile vous
pouvez le voir à l'image ça casse avec
une simple pression mais les tests
réalisés en laboratoire ont montré que
grâce au millefeuille de résine la route
solaire peut supporter le passage d'un
million de poids lourds ça représente
environ 200 poids lourds par jour
pendant 10 ans philippe raffin nous
explique où s installer
sur le principe ou à tous et peut
s'installer sur n'importe quelle route
donc je vous parlais de parking ça peut
être des voies de circulation en zone
urbaine des bois blancs à faible trafic
dans un premier temps avec une
prospective de pouvoir décliner sur des
zones à plus fort trafic
alors comment va être utilisé l'énergie
solaire dégagé par cet automne âge il
est déjà prévu plusieurs usages il sera
possible d'alimenter dans des foyers
une vingtaine de mètres carrés ça
représente à peu près deux places de
parking ça alimente un foyers hors
chauffage électrique
ça pourra aussi faire de l'éclairage
public puisque un kilomètre de route
solaire ça fait de l'éclairage urbain
pour une ville de 5000 habitants et dans
les réflexions futur des chercheurs les
voitures pourraient aussi grâce à la
route solaire se recharger en roulant
alors quand est-ce qu'on pourra peut
être voir à ses panneaux sur nos routes
mènent leur floral la phase de tests
allaient maintenant terminée et
l'entreprise espère une
commercialisation d'ici 2016 avait donc
il faut un peu attendre avant de les
voir merci mélanie est ce que ce que
nous pouvons admirer voire à dès ce soir
c'est une certitude c'est un grand match
du moins on l'espère en football le choc
est programmé ce soir au parc des
princes le paris saint germain qui
s'entraîne au camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye reçoit le real de
madrid de cristiano ronaldo pour la
ligue des champions
l'enjeu de cette rencontre c'est la
première place du groupe
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
et fanny bourdon l'élève contre le
maître le paris saint-germain
prétendants un premier sacre européen en
fin de saison affronte ce soir au parc
des princes le real madrid en phase de
poules de la ligue des champions une
équipe qui très différent c'est un
record historiquement le gouffre est
abyssal mais sur le papier l'écart entre
les espagnols et le club local s'est
resserrée et coéquipiers de zlatan
ibrahimovic peuvent bousculer l'équipe
madrilène sur leur pelouse
énormément évolué ces dernières années
parti mardi qu'il vendait des bons
joueurs c'est leur coeur l'ex-canari
haut niveau je pense qu'ils ont
j'ai envie de montrer d'eux est montré
sur la scène européenne
parce qu'on a les qualités pour gagner
la motivation pour le faire on est à
domicile dans l'est chez nous parce que
l'année dernière est arrivé aussi aux
barcelonais va marcher mais voilà ça on
est capable de le faire
est-ce qu'on va le faire demain jeu est
privé du français karim benzema et du
gallois gareth bale blessé le real
madrid pourra compter sur sa star
portugaise cristiano ronaldo le meilleur
buteur de l'histoire du real a déjà
marqué à cinq reprises dans cette ligue
des champions
ces recettes sera sans aucun doute un
poison pour la défense parisienne le psg
en a conscience
au moins c'est stable à ce moment il
fait partie des deux séjours en cas de
victoire contre le real madrid le pg
comptabiliserait 9 points dans cette
ligue des champions la qualification
sera alors presque acquise et culture à
présent venise se transporte à
versailles avec cette exposition du
photographe philippe calandre à l'espace
serait chaud de versailles c'est ce
qu'ont position photographie d'une
venise imaginaire entre documents et
collages admirer jusqu'au 8 novembre
sephora namani et patrick jacques de
dixmude philippe calandre ou photographe
d'origine pressé mode a souhaité se
distancier de la réalité en recréant des
images connu pour ses photos montages de
zones industrielles
cet amateur d'architecturé propose une
nouvelle série de compositions autour
d'une venise onirique au fil des années
je me suis un petit peu lassé de
de la réalité j'ai décidé de
reconstruire ma propre réalité en
en allant vers l'utopie pourrait bien
cette photo une composition qui part de
plusieurs images de plusieurs fragments
je dirais avec ses différents fragments
j'ai géré composer une image qui paraît
être une véritable image mais qui n'en
est pas une à partir de clichés de
bâtiments réels réalisés à venise avec
un argentique philippe calendreau
propose au bout d'un an de travail
cette composition photographique deal
fictives ces images sont obtenus par
photomontage sur ordinateur avec
toujours le souci de respecter la
direction de la lumière la difficulté
dans ses prises de vue était de combiner
deux types d'architecturés opposé c'est
à dire larchitecture de venise
traditionnel avec tout ce que cela
comporte
dans les ornements
et une autre architecture qui est celle
que l'on cache le plus souvent ils
architecturaux porto marghera qui la
ville industrielle à proximité de venise
mais le but était de joindre ses deux
architectures cette exposition présentée
à l'espace richaud de versailles
jusqu'au 8 novembre a été commandé
initialement par l'architecte jean
michel wilmotte pour sa fondation
vénitienne c'est la fin de cette édition
mais avant de nous quitter je vous
propose de regarder ces images c'est un
petit clin d'oeil fait par le
technocentre de renault à guyancourt
pour ce mercredi 21 octobre
le technocentre exposé la delorean
voitures mythiques en ce jour où marty
mcfly héros de la trilogie culte des
années 80 est censé arriver en
provenance du passé donc le 21 octobre
dans le deuxième volet de la saga il
voyage dans le temps avec doc à bord de
la mythique voiture pour atterrir à
notre époque
voilà de quoi réjouir les fans celle à
20 maintenant de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis à suivre qu'est-ce que
présenté par sephora namani pour ma part
je vous retrouve demain à 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
en direct je vous souhaite une très
agréable soirée